You took me off tumeric and curcuclear and I added intensity and porttide to see if the
rash would go away.
So this person had a rash and what we were trying to see is if the possibility of the
rash was due to a sensitivity or that the person has antibodies to tumeric.
So tumeric is a food, it's a spice, right?
And you can develop antibodies to tumeric, it's not really very common but I've seen it
before.
So you do a Syrex 10 panel, it measures for all sorts of different things and one of
them is tumeric and I've seen people have positive antibodies for tumeric, they can't take
tumeric and I was just curious to see if this person's rash was due to the tumeric so I had
them go off of the tumeric to see if the rash would go away without having to spend 500
plus dollars to do a Syrex array 10.
It says now my rash is increased to other areas and I'm wondering if not reacting to the
enzymes.
You'll see, this is a call in a elimination diet, you're trying to eliminate things that you
think could possibly be causing a rash.
You could certainly eliminate the intense ion portate, I just highly doubt that the rash
is due to the enzymes, I think it's something else.
If the rash didn't go away and it seemed to get worse after you went off the tumeric, then
certainly not the tumeric, I'd go back on that for sure because that's going to be a good
anti-inflammatory.
There's something else going on, there's something maybe in your diet that is causing it, you're
going to have to continue to kind of look at things that maybe in your diet that could
be causing the rash.
There's just so many things, there's going to be another rash question coming up.
There's just so many things that could cause a rash.
Usually it's a histamine type reaction, but it could be histamine reaction from something,
you're breathed in, from something, you're eating food wise, from dyes, calories, chemicals,
something you're exposed to just outside in your yard, you're, oh, I just started this
rash a month ago.
Well, maybe it's just because you just started getting outside in the summertime, maybe it's
from something you're spraying on your lawn, I mean, there's just, you have to kind of
be an investigator to try to figure some of this stuff out, even running some functional
medicine panels might not pinpoint why the person has the rash, so because it's something
in the environment that you can't always test for.
With the increased dose of the intense I'm forte in the last three days, I've noticed
a returning the rash to my neck, and it could be that, so let's eliminate that, let's see
if that's it, that could be, I'd kind of doubt that if that's it, but anything's possible.
The neck and knee rash is itch, I wonder if the enzymes could be causing the rash as I
noticed it increase in gas with the new changes, well, I think that's a little bit different.
Prairie position, what physician wants me to go on an oral antibiotic for my left knee rash,
and by wondering how this will current, well, I don't understand why an oral antibiotic for a rash.
So an antibiotic is only going to help a bacterial infection, so let's see things that the
rash has caused from a bacterial infection, which it possibly could be, but with gut issues,
I don't know if I would jump to that right away. Doing another cheek swab might be helpful, too.
I would go back to my first idea of making sure that you're doing some different food
eliminations to see if there's anything else that you could be reacting to.
Interrash question from somebody a few weeks ago, too, and it's, you can eat things like,
don't think that, oh, I'm going to eat this for so long, it certainly can't be that.
You can develop antibodies to things that you eat a lot of, and that's one of the reasons why
you can develop antibodies to things that is because you eat a lot of them and you've eaten them for a
long time. So just because you've never had a problem, quote unquote, with that thing in the past,
doesn't mean you want to the future, or that might be what is currently the cause of the problem.
So if you're going to try to get to the bottom of this with an elimination diet that you're going to
eliminate is many of these dietary things that you might be causing it as well.